Hi, everybody. Happy Wednesday,
and thank you for joining
us for our monthly workflows with
Posit Team's session.
By popular demand,
today we're gonna talk about
using your company brand in a
shiny app. While this
example highlights shiny,
you can also use all of
these techniques with Quarto and R
Markdown documents.
I found that incorporating
your company brand can make an
impact on your
data storytelling,
but making a great
first impression.
You can elevate the
initial perceived quality of your
content and encourage
greater adoption.
So I'm really excited for us
to go through this example today.
And as a reminder,
we host these sessions on
the last Wednesday of every month
at the same time and same
place here on YouTube where you can
find the recordings of the
nine previous sessions as well.
If you have suggestions or
a workflow that would help make
life a bit easier for you,
please let us know in the
YouTube chat here or over on
Slido if you prefer
to be anonymous.
You can use YouTube and
Slido to ask questions during the
demo today as well. At
the end of the demo,
you'll be automatically
directed over into another
YouTube live room
for our Q and A.
With that, I would love
to introduce Garrett,
Director of developer
relations at Posit,
and one of the
earliest employees at rstudio.
Among many other things,
Garrett is the co author of r
for data science and an author
of the lubridate package.
Thank you so much, Garrett.
I'll turn it over to you.
We're going to start with a
basic app that looks like this.
And slowly turn it into an app
that looks like this. Along the way,
we'll lay out the components of
the app with the Bslib library
We'll add cards and value boxes
with icons like you see here.
We'll add a logo.
We'll change the color
theme to use brand colors.
We'll apply the theme to
our plots and we'll change the
fonts that appear with
throughout the app.
I'll also link to GitHub in my
app and publish the app to Posit connect.
Now, this app is written in R,
and that will be our
focus today. However,
everything that we can do,
you can also do with shiny
app written in Python,
but of course, the code that
you would use would be different.
So let's get started, and that
means logging in to an IDE
where we could develop
our code. For me,
that means Posit workbench.
And inside of Posit workbench,
I prefer to work in
the RStudio Pro IDE.
So I'll make that selection and start
a new section for us to work in.
So workbench launches, and
here's the RStudio IDE.
The next thing I need to do
is get the code that contains my
app. So I've already
been working on this app,
not
necessarily collaboratively,
but I have prior art that
I want to start with.
And that code lives on GitHub
in this public repo. It's
Garrettgmman/shiny-styling-demo.
So if you wanted, you could
download this code for
yourself, clone
the git repository,
and that's what
I'm going to do.
I'm going to clone it
into my workbench session.
To do that, I'll copy the URL.
I'll go back to RStudio,
and I'll make a new project.
When I make that project,
I can choose to make it
from a version control repo.
In this case, it's a Git repo,
and I pasted in
the GitHub repo.
I also need to choose a
directory name to clone that
repo into in my
local file structure.
I'm going to shiny
styling demo.
So I create that project,
RStudio clones the
repo, imports the code,
refreshes the R session,
And now I have all the
contents to that github repo.
These are local copies that I
could work with and then if I
wanted to, I could push them
back to GitHub, you know,
with typical git
development practices.
RStudio adds a git pain here,
which is a gooey pain that I
could use to do the typical git
work, like, commit, push,
pull, create branches, revert, and
so on. Today, let's just focus
on working with the apps.
Within this repository,
you'll find a folder called
finished app This contains the
code that creates the
finished app we looked at,
but we're going to go look at
this today because we're going to make this,
and we're going to make it
from the directory called Bear app.
That contains the first app
we saw. If I run the app,
we could take a look
at what it does.
So this app contains data
for a fictitious company called DemoCo.
Or DemoCo.
They sell, imagine them
selling a freemium software product.
Users can use the
product for free,
but they can also upgrade
to a paid professional level service
with more features.
DemoCo is interested in what
they could do to convince their
users to upgrade to the
paid professional version,
so they've tried out two types
of free trials that last a
different amount of time. One
last thirty days, that's trial
A, one last one hundred days.
And the app shows data that
they've collected over the past
year at the success of the
free trials at converting users into customers
versus the success of not
offering a free trial.
It's designed to be a
portal that we could give executives
so they could query
the data themselves.
For example, they can filter
down to specific customer segments
within the data and the
app will respond to their selections.
So that's what the app does,
but I don't think this
app looks very good.
I like the sidebar layout that
puts all of the inputs right
where you expect to find them,
but this endless scroll
is not very user friendly.
Also, this looks like a basic
shiny app out of the box.
It doesn't really look like a
product that DemoCo might use internally.
So let's see what we
can do to change that.
Now we're going to
start working this code,
and to make it easier
for us to follow along,
I'm going to add an
extra column to my IDE.
I can do that by going
to this panel icon, and selecting pane
layout, and they'll
just add a column.
I'll apply that.
And then I could put
some code side by side.
And that's what I'll do. First,
I'll take the base code we'll
put over here. This is our app.
And in this untitled document,
I'll just copy all this code
into it. So no matter How
far field we go we at
least have, you know,
some safe ground return to.
We could close the finished app,
and we're not going to
use these panes too often,
so I'll minimize those just so
we have some more screen real estate.
I'm using a large font size, so
not as much of it's in here,
but I'm hoping you'll be able
to see the typing a little better.
So we want to create a new UI.
So out this goes,
and let's just pause for a
minute to reflect on what our
strategy is gonna be. First,
we're gonna give the
app a new layout.
Then we will
add cards and value boxes.
We'll see what those
are as we add them.
Next, we'll add a logo
Then we'll change
the theme of the app,
and we'll work with
the colors in the app.
Then finally, we will work
with the fonts in the app.
And then super finally,
we'll publish the app.
Right. So how do we do this?
How do we change these
components of a shiny app?
Well,
there's one package in
particular that we're going to
use to do most of these
tasks, and that package is called the
bslib package.
So bslib stands for
Bootstrap Library,
and Bootstrap is a very popular
framework for CSS and
HTML development. And every shiny
app is boot built on top
of the bootstrap framework.
What bslibdoes is it provides the
most new and up to date
bootstrap features in an art
package so our users can take
advantage of those features.
It works seamlessly with shiny
apps because it's developed by
the shiny team.
It also works with our markdown
documents and even quarto
documents because those documents
are also built upon Bootstrap.
In fact, bslib is so integrated
into shiny that is imported by
the shiny package. So if
you've installed the shiny package,
you already have it and you could
start to use it in your app.
And that's what I'll do here.
I will tell the app that we're
going to start using some
functions that come
from the bslib package,
do that with library bslib,
And then the first functions
we'll use will recreate the app
page for us.
Now I said that I really
liked the sidebar layout and I meant
it and that's what I want
to create, a page with the side
bar. Typically in shiny,
you might do that by
calling fluidPage,
giving a title panel,
you'll call side bar layout,
and give that a sidebar
panel, and also a main panel,
and you'll put your
contents inside of there.
BSLid provides a slightly more efficient
way to create a sidebar app.
So let's take a look.
We'll use the function page
sidebar, which comes in BSlib.
It takes a title argument
We don't need to use
the Title Panel helper.
We could just pass the
title straight to that argument.
So I'll copy and paste
that from over here.
And next it takes
a sidebar argument,
and we use a helper
function called sidebar with that argument.
Whatever we put inside sidebar
will appear in the sidebar
and I have this object
called sidebar content
We'll look at it in a second,
but it contains everything
I want in the sidebar.
And then finally,
to use page sidebar,
anything you want
in the main panel,
you just list as
additional arguments outside of sidebar.
So we put everything
else here. Literally.
Now if we run this app,
we'll see what we get. So
this is our sidebar app,
and one thing I want you to
notice right off the bat is The
styling for this sidebar
app is a little more modern,
a little more up to date versus
the typical shiny sidebar app. For example,
we have a built in widget
to expand and close the side bar,
and you can see other
styling differences as well.
So where did these things come
from? If anyone's curious,
these are three
widgets and some text,
and I saved them as a list in
a helper file called setup.R,
that my app is sourcing.
So down here, you see an
object called sidebar content,
which is a list.
This idea of grouping widgets
together in list is a really
helpful pattern if you plan to
use the same set of widgets in
multiple places throughout a shiny
app or across shiny apps.
I'm just using it today to
keep screen real estate focused on
the things we're actually
going to be touching.
So that's where sidebar
content comes from.
Now everything
else I just typed,
but that's not really
what we want in our app.
We want these things
from our old app over here.
Let's pull just a couple of
them into our app so we could
start work with laying them out
before the screen gets too crowded.
So if I put things
into my page sidebar,
bslib or shiny,
we'll add them one
beneath the other as if each new
item was placed in a new row.
And if I continue to do
that with all the items I have,
I'll be back at
that endless scroll,
which is what I'm
trying to avoid.
Really what I want to do
is place the items beside each
other as if each new
item was a new column,
and there's a function in bslib
that allows me to do that.
It's called layout_columns.
Let's add that here and
see what happens. Call
layout_columns and
you give it as much
content as you want.
I close the parentheses.
Now if I run the
app, those items
are organized into columns.
So this is good.
This is a start,
but we can see a
couple things here.
The first thing I see is These
are four different items,
but the character strings are
really just titles for the
plots, and they should
probably travel together.
I don't want them
in separate columns,
I want each title and
plot in a single column,
and then the next title
and plot and so on.
In a shiny app,
you might collect these things
together with something like a
well panel, but bslib
introduces a new concept called
a card that I'm
going to use here.
If I want to collect two
things together in a card,
I surround them in
the function card.
And then if I want the card
to have a title or a header,
I would wrap that in
another function called card header.
The reason for that is it'll
make it easier for us to style
that header a little later on.
So go ahead and do that.
And then we can take a
look at what we have.
Alright,
so now our apps and our
titles are bound together visually in
a way that I think
looks really attractive.
There's even a drop
shadow in there,
and we have our app starting
to look like where we're headed to.
The next thing I think I want
to do is I want to change the
width of these two plots.
I think the line chart deserves
more width than the bar chart
We'll just make it easier
to see what's going on there,
and maybe those dates won't
be scrunched together.
And so I'm going to try to
make the line chart about twice as
wide as the bar chart.
The layout columns function makes it
really easy for us to do that.
We can do that by
adding a new argument called col_widths.
An underscore in there, and we
set it to a vector of numbers,
one number per column
to set the width for.
Right now we have two cards,
that means two columns,
and I want to make the
first card eight units wide,
and the next card
four units wide.
Now why am I choosing
those numbers?
Layout_columns is going to
take whatever horizontal space is
available to it, and divide
it into twelve relative units.
They're relative because you don't
know how wide the user's
window is going to be and
the user might actually change the
width of the window
while they're at it.
But layout columns will make
sure it's always dividing the
available space in the twelve,
and now I'm just apportioning that
twelve units between these two cards.
And here we go. I've created
that that width that I like,
but there's more cards to add
to this app and I want the
extra cards to be on a
new row below these cards.
I could do that with the
same layout columns function.
Here's how it works.
If I want to pull over
the remaining elements,
Just start with one element.
I'd add it here. I'm gonna, as
before, wrap these things into a card.
And then as before, I'm gonna
give this new card a width.
Let's say we want this to
be four units wide as well.
Layout_columns divides
everything in twelve units.
So if you ask for which that
exceeds the twelve units,
the outcomes will simply put it
on a new row below the first.
So this four unit wide card
will spill over onto a second row.
And this is how I create a
grid of columns and rows.
I just plan out the units
and put things where I want them.
I could even offset things
in here. If you want negative
space somewhere in your
column or your row,
Just say how wide do you want
that space to be and then put a
negative number in front of it.
So I could insert three units
of negative space here I have
four numbers now,
only three cards,
but that's because one of
the numbers refers to empty space.
And now when I make this app,
provide it's wide enough.
I see I've moved
that recommended trial over.
That gives me a lot of freedom.
I don't really advantage
that for you today,
but I wanted to
show that to you.
What I want to do now is
pull in everything and make the final layout.
Now as before I
wanna be careful to
collect these items together,
where they belong together.
Bear with me while I do that.
Make sure I close
every new function.
Alright. So I have
some new cards,
so I should apply
some new widths here.
Let's make every
card except the last
one four units wide.
That will take us
another twelve units.
That'll be a second row.
And then the last card,
I'll have span an
entire row by itself.
We'll make it
twelve units wide.
Uh-oh, it looks like I forgot
a comma in this case.
These are all arguments,
the layout's columns function,
so we gotta have commas
between each new one.
And here we go.
We have our app.
Now I have all the widths
the way I like them.
But I don't have the
heights the way I like them.
I prefer to give a little
more height to the charts.
There's more visual information
there. And this table,
you know, we could
scroll within the card,
so I don't mind compressing
that a little bit.
The way I affect the row
heights is by adding a row
heights argument to layout.
Columns. So I have three rows.
I want them to have relative
units of four, one
point five and three.
Now, no matter what
numbers I put in here,
layout_columns is going to
use the entire vertical space
But by choosing four,
one, five, and three,
I'm determining how wide those
rows are relative to each other.
And there we go. Now
this is all laid out,
but there is something I see
here. I see a lost opportunity
Each of the cards in the
center row only shows off one value.
Bslib provides a new object
called a value box that can
really emphasize single values.
And I'm not using it,
but I would sure like to.
So let's go back to our code
The way to use value box is
to call the function value
box from the bslib library.
And value box doesn't require
a value header or anything like
that. We just give it a title,
and then we give it the content
we want to appear in that value box.
Let's make all three value
boxes at the same time.
And rerun our app.
Here we go. So now
these are value boxes.
One of the the big advantages
using a value box is you can
add an icon to that value box
to explain something or draw
your user's attention or just
make your app look
a certain way.
So I'm going to add icons
to these value boxes.
The value box function takes
an argument called showcase.
And showcase should be set
to some sort of icon. Now,
how do you write
an icon in R? Well,
there's a couple packages
that can help you do that.
Like the font awesome package
for font awesome icons,
but I'm going to use
the bsicons package,
which contains bootstrap icons.
There's about five thousand
icons that come with bootstrap.
As I mentioned, we're
using bootstrap all over,
so I like the idea
of just sticking with those icons.
But there's five
thousand icons.
How do I know which ones I
want to use? Well, for that,
you might turn to
Google or the web.
I think this is the best
website for searching through
Bootstrap icons, they're all here.
You see there's quite a
few, and there's a
search box at the top.
So if I want an icon
related to money,
I might do this and see
some things this coin one catches my
eye, and so on. I'll try
to make sure this link ends up
next to the video
that you're watching.
Alright. So let's go back
to our app. Let's make
some icons. So I've
loaded the package
Now, to pass an
icon to showcase,
I use this helper
function called bs_underscore icon,
and I give it the
name of my icon.
So I looked through the
icons before we met today,
and I decided I'd like to
use an icon called Stars for this
value box, which presents
a recommendation.
And I would like to use an icon
called
People-fill for this
number of users.
And finally,
for this average spending,
I want to use that coin
icon we just looked at.
Now I rerun the app
and I give enough space.
We have the icons.
Not only that,
they introduce some
color into our app.
This isn't the color I want
to use at the end of the day,
but anywhere you see
color in your app,
you can change the color later
on to make it fit your theme.
So this gives us
something to work with.
Now this is a nice looking app.
There's one last thing I want
to add to it before I start
tweaking the details and
that is my company's logo.
I'm gonna put it right here in
the side bar. And to do that,
I'm really just gonna rely on
the fact that this app is a
HTML webpage. I use HTML to
drop an image right in there,
and then the user's browser
could place that image into the
app the way they place an image
into any webpage that the user looks at.
To make that work, takes a
two step process and is shiny.
The first step is I have
to get the image to the
user's web browser. And in
shiny, you do that by give by
supplying a WWW folder. This
is a special folder in shiny.
Everything in the app directory is
going to be passed to the
server that serves your
shiny app. So the server, for
example, have access to
all the helper functions,
the data set that uses to
build the plots and whatnot,
but it's not going to be
passed to user's web browser There's
no reason that gives user
that data causes security problems, maybe.
Definitely makes the
download time increase.
It just doesn't make sense,
so it doesn't happen.
But sometimes you do want
to give something to the user's
web browser, like a CSS file or
an image in our case, and you
could do that by putting
it in an older named WWW,
I've put our logo here in
this folder along with another file.
I'll talk about later.
Here's the logo.
It's just a PNG image. Anything
in this WWW folder will be
given to the user's web browser
where it's available at the top
level of their web page.
Alright, so that's step one.
Users go get this image,
but where should
the browser put it?
I have to tell the browser
that And like I said,
I'm just going to
use basic HTML,
skills are a little
undeveloped or rusty,
but I think you'll
remember an image tag,
Let's use single quotes,
something like image,
and then I have
to set the source.
The source is going to be
this file, which I sent,
it's available
at the top level.
I'll set the width.
Gonna make it a hundred
percent of the sidebar.
And then for the height,
I don't really know what it
would be, but just, you know,
whatever works out when
the width's one hundred percent.
So I'll use auto.
And there I've written the HTML
tag and you could look this up
on Google if you need to see
how to put an image tag in
there, but it's just
a character string.
If I leave it like this,
shiny's going to think it's
a character string that I want
shiny to display in
the side bar. Instead,
I want shiny to treat
it Create it as HTML,
so I'm going to surround
it with this HTML helper function
from the shiny package.
Now, when I run the app,
Yeah.
The browser puts an
image right there.
It's a little hard to see,
but there's some white
text in this image.
It's the complete
logo, but Obviously,
when I came up with this logo,
I was envisioning an app
with a dark background.
So let's shift gears and
start tweaking the app changing the
colors, changing the fonts and
getting it ready to publish.
How do we change the colors
in the app? Well, once again,
we're going to use
the bslib package
And this time, we're going
to use an argument called theme
that comes in the page function
from bslib and we're going to
set it equal to bs_theme,
also from the bslib
package. WithinBS theme,
we could choose any
Boot Swatch theme
like the minty
theme, for example,
and tell bslib to use that
theme for our app. A theme
controls colors, fonts, All
the styling in your app.
This didn't change anything,
so I must have missed
something here.
BStheme.
Bootsategy.
Let's try this again.
For my arguments here,
boot swatch, minty.
Got commas. I got
parenthesis. Although,
it does seem like what I just
did, so let's rerun this.
Okay.
And And let's see if
the console is telling something's missing.
Alright. Well,
I'll stop the app I'm not
sure what's going on here,
but one thing that I can do
is restart the R session.
Sometimes when you're
working with theming,
there is some caching that
happens in the the browser and
in other places and
restarting our session,
we'll rule that
out as a challenge.
And here we go.
So this is a new
theme. It looks a little different.
It's the minty theme.
I could even see some of
my logo text here. However,
this is not necessarily the theme
that I want my app to have.
It's just a demonstration that we
could change everything all at once.
That's always a
good way to start.
Let's suppose
we don't know any
Boot Swatch themes.
How do we choose
the theme for us?
Bootswatch comes with another
terrific function called BSthemer,
and you can put it inside
your server function,
then when you run your app,
your app will have a widget
up here in the corner
that allows you to try out
different themes to see how it
looks in your app.
So, for example,
could try out the
superhero theme.
Kinda nice,
we could, we could try
out any of these themes.
These are all Boot Swatch
themes that come with our app.
This one might be good
if we're wireframing something to have
discussions about it.
I like the darkly theme,
and that's where I'm
going to take this up.
I'm going to start here. But I
don't like it out of the box.
I do want to change
things in the theme,
and I could do some of that
right here with BS Themer. For example,
I could change the foreground color
to a color of my choosing.
So let's keep this So I'd paste
it back in here in a second,
but I know that this
light blue from democo is
A color that I believe is,
here. Let me look it up in
my notes so I don't get Yes.
It's eight six c seven e d.
So I could take the darkly
theme and change the foreground
color to be this color.
I like how these
letters are this color.
It really pulls the
branding through,
but I really hate how these
fields in the sidebar of that
color. I really expect
those to stay white.
So maybe I'm not going
to do this instead. I'll
return this to
what it used to be,
but I have other ways to
put the color in here.
There's several accent
colors used by every app,
and I could change those
Although the way I've
written this app,
it's not really taking
advantage of those accent
colors, but I
could change them.
I could change the fonts
of the app as we go.
That's, not something I'll
do here, but as an option,
I could change other
options. For example,
I could turn box shadows,
and maybe mess
with the spacing.
And let's let's change
one accent color.
What do what happens
if I change that to g?
Well, I crashed the app.
But every time I made a
change in the app, in the
console back here,
we weren't looking at it
But the themer was printing the
code we would need to apply
that custom scheme we came up
with to our app.
We could take these arguments
that happen after theme,
and we could put
them right into
bs_theme up here.
And then we'd have the theme
that we were looking at.
Now, I didn't really like
anything I was doing there,
but I did like that.
There's a darkly theme and
my app looked good with it,
so I'll start there. Instead of
using the themer to change the
components of my app,
I think I'll manually
change the components.
So let's stop whatever
happened there.
Here's my app with
the darkly theme.
Here's what I want to do to it.
I want to make all this
text blue while keeping this white.
I want to make some
of these backgrounds a different color.
I want to change the fonts to
reflect the fonts and the logo. Essentially,
I want to touch everything in
this app to make it a little
different And by doing that,
we'll be able to survey
together all our options for
changing styling piece
by piece inside our shiny
Sounds like a lot, but it's
not. Let's get started.
So the first thing we can
do The easiest thing might be to
change the background
of the value boxes.
Each value box takes a theme
argument, and I could set that
to a hard coded color or
even one of those colors that
we were looking at
before like primary,
secondary success These are all
colors defined with each theme.
And if I reload this app,
I'll see that this value box
has the success color, so now
it's showing up in our app.
The other value boxes I'm
going to make the secondary color.
It's a shade of gray.
It doesn't look very different from
before, but it to my eyes,
it looks a little more
inviting a little warmer.
There we go. We have the
secondary color there. Now,
I don't like this green color.
It has nothing to
do with my brand,
but it does give me
a method for changing
this color here.
I could change the color
value of the secondary color,
the primary color,
any of the colors in the theme
in the Boot Swatch theme in the
BS theme function. So if I
want the success color to be
my
86c7ed color,
I could set it here. Now,
everywhere that success
color appears in the app,
it'll be that blue, which
means I've now made that value
box my company color,
which is great.
Next,
I'll use that success color to
make the other parts of this
app, the company color as well.
So
going back
to here.
We have the card headers.
That's where our text appears.
The method I'm going to use
to change the color of the card
headers will be to
assign them a CSS class.
A CSS class is just a
set of styling rules like color, font
family, size, whatever,
that get supplied to the
objects that share that class.
The bootstrap framework is
just a collection of many, many
CSS classes that all
do different things,
but all look good together.
If I can find a Bootstrap
class that changes the text to the
success color,
then I could use that class here
because card header has a class argument.
Now where would I find the name
of the CSS class that does what
I want to do? Not even someone
who uses CSS on a regular basis.
Well,
there is a page that has all
of the Bootstrap CSS classes,
and we could search through it.
If I'm looking for a class that
affects text,
could start to look through
classes that use text.
And I might notice that there's
these are the colors that come
with the theme, a primary
color, secondary color, success color.
I could do some experimentation and
I have and I discover that
text-success makes the text of
any object you give this class
the color that is
the success color.
If I want to use it, I
don't need to pay attention to that
dot. I can just take
the name of the class,
and pass it to that
class argument. So this would be
text-success.
And I could reuse
that in any object
whose text I want to be the color
of success. I'll be all my card headers.
Let's reload the app
and see the effect.
So now nothing's changed
except the color of text,
and it's the success
color. That's very good.
The next piece of text
that I want to well,
Eventually,
I'll color this text too,
but I'll use a different
method to do that.
I will use this class method
to change the background of the
side I would like the
background to be like these backgrounds.
And there's a Bootstrap
class for doing that.
And like everything else,
the sidebar function
takes a class argument.
Through experimentation, and induction.
I figured out that
the bootstrap class,
CSS class that would make
the background success
would be that. Don't
want to be blue,
I want it to be the
secondary color.
So bg-secondary will change
that background color.
So the class of this object
comes with a styling roll says
his background is this
color, the secondary color.
It's looking pretty good.
Alright. Now I have
this text down here.
Let's make that Blue as well. I
looked and I looked and I could
not find a CSS class that
would change this text.
But the latest editions of
Bootstrap have something beyond
CSS classes
that I can rely on, and
those are variables.
See what I mean about
variables. Let's come over here
to the bslib page
under the theming section,
there's an article that lists
all the theming variables.
Alright. Here's some variables.
For each of these, there is
a CSS class or multiple CSS
classes that use these values.
So there's some
class that says,
make the text this gray value,
but it doesn't say F8F9FA.
It says make it
gray one hundred,
and then gray one hundred is
a variable that contains the
value to use.
If I change the value contained
in gray one hundred, then every
class that uses gray-100
will be updated, and so my
change will propagate or dare
we say cascade through my
app. Using this variable system.
I think you could kind
of imagine how it works.
If you realize that success,
the success color is a variable.
As its primary,
secondary, and so on.
So when I changed success, I
changed all the places that use
success to use that blue color.
Now, the question is,
are there any variables
that affect tables?
Well, we could search for
variables that affect tables.
And one thing I noticed
is there's a variable called Table-color.
I wondered
what color gets changed
to playing out the background
because there's a
variable called Table-bg.
And just by trying it out,
I saw that it is the color
of the text in the table.
So if I want the color of
the text in table to be a different
value, I'll just set this
to a different value.
And where do I set that?
I set that in the
Bs-theme function just like when I
change the success variable
to be a different value.
So now this variable the
table-color.
I'm gonna say equals
that same blue.
We load the app. And
voila,
starting to get
where we want to go.
Now there's one big hole in
the color theming of this app so
far, and that's the plots.
Now,
each of those plots are made with
g g pot two and with ggplot2,
you can control everything and
I mean everything about the
visual appearance of a plot.
But it does take a lot of
typing to fix all that to make
it look like something custom,
and I'd rather skip over that.
Luckily, I can. There is
an amazingly magical way to make
your plots match
the rest of the app.
And that is with a
package called thematic.
So I'll load the package in
my app with Library(thematic) and then
Thematic comes with a function
called thematic_shiny.
When you add that to your app,
every base R plot every
lattice plot and every ggplot2
will automatically inherit the styling
of the app that surrounds it.
So let's give that a
try. I'll reload the app.
And you see right away,
with that one line of code,
my plots now look like
they belong here in this darkly
themed app. And it looks like
they're using a set of colors.
I didn't really mess with,
but they look good in the
app because That's how darkly theme
works. It's decided things
that look good together. Alright,
now this is a really nicely
colored app. I want to change
the fonts though.
There's several ways to
change the fonts in an app,
but they all rely
on variables. So
There are three variables, that's
what in most of our
ways. That change fonts. One
of them is called Basefont.
One of them is
called heading_font,
and one of them is
called code_font.
I don't have any code appearing in
my app so I won't be working
with code_font. And just
for discussion right now,
let's stick to
just one of these.
Let's try to change
the base font.
To change one of
these font variables,
we could pass up
the name of any
website on,
the font that every browsers
go know and have access to.
We can pass a single value
here, or it could be,
vector of several fonts,
so you have backup
fonts for some reason,
one font doesn't work.
I'll reload that app.
We should be able to see
that some texts become times new
Roman, It has. I definitely
don't want to keep that,
but I wanted to see
that this works.
But it's not going to work for
me because I want to change the
font to something that's
not universally known.
For example, I might want
to change it to Pacifico,
which is a Google font
made available by Google,
not too hard to get, but it's
not a web safe font. So if I
just ran this,
the browser probably wouldn't
know what Pacifico is.
To pass that information
to the browser,
I could use the helper
font_Google for any Google
based font, use font Google
If your user's browser
does not have that font,
font Google will download it and
cache it for the user so
they can use it
to see your app.
So here's Pacifico.
Makes a big difference.
It's also not the font we want
to use at the end of the day,
but the font we do want
to use, it's called Lato.
Is essentially
the default font.
Why are we going to use it?
Because it's the font
that appears in my logo.
So this is Latto. It's the
same font from the subtitle,
highly flexible solutions.
Doesn't make a good example
today because it is the default
font, but this is how we'd
swap that out. Next, let's swap the
headings to use
the demo code font.
That is a different font yet.
That font is called open
sauce sans, it's not a
Google font at all.
It's just a font that I
actually have the style file,
the font file for. And if I
want to use it, I could give
that file to my user's browser and
then tell them to use that font.
This is a fool proof way
for getting any font into your
shiny app. So to give the
fonts a user's browser,
I put it in this www folder.
And the next I tell the app
to use it for the headings.
The way I do that is
I set heading font To a different
helper function, this
time is font_face.
The way font face works,
First I give the font a name.
Open Sauce Sans in case I
want to refer to it anywhere.
And then I have to tell it
where that font lives.
And this is a little tricky.
It's something you might want to
look up because you have to
use CSS
syntax here. And the way the
syntax works out is you pass a
URL, which is a file path,
to your font file, assuming
the font file is at the top
level directory
of the web page.
Which is where it will be,
since I put in WWW folder.
Hopefully, I spell that
correctly, but it doesn't end
there. You have to tell the CSS
one the format to that file is.
In our case, the format
is truetype. That's what the
TTF means, true type font.
And now if I have done
this right and have the
right number parentheses,
You can reload the app.
And I don't see that
working, so I either missed something
we need to restart R.
Here are open sauce
sans regular. Open sauce sans
regular. DTF
format.
Yeah, I didn't close this.
So I had opened a quotation mark
around this file path, I didn't close.
This time I closed it.
And now we see that there's
a legitimate change here in the
header It looks like
the democo logo.
But oddly these card headers
don't follow that new font.
You might not notice it, but
I notice it. It's weird to me,
but the card headers
aren't considered header classes.
I can make them header classes
and then they would use the
header font And I
will do that using the
I have a little bigger first.
Using the class arguments
that I already put in here.
I can give each of these
multiple classes with the same
class argument. For example,
if I gave it the H1 class,
as well as tech success,
it'd be a H1 header.
That's a first level
header. That's actually really big.
I don't want to do that.
I want it to be maybe
a six level header,
h6 that make it the same size
it is, but it technically be a
header, so it would
inherit the header font,
as well as inheriting
the success text color.
Let's give that a try.
Alright. There we go. We
have the the fonts here and
in all these places.
So this is how the finished
app looks minus a couple things
that gitlink, some other things,
but it is ready to publish.
Now, if you want to
publish a styled app,
there's a couple things I can
I suggest you consider doing,
and I'm going to do them
right now? The first is,
We should hard code into
here the version of Bootstrap that
we're using. Bootstrap gets
updated from time to time.
This is always going to
use the latest version of bootstrap,
but we want to let an update
to change the way our app looks.
We might not like the change.
So what we could do is
we find out what version of Bootstrap
are using today with
the function version_default, version
five, and then we could
add that as an argument
to BS_theme. Now,
this will always use
version five of bootstrap,
to recreate the theme that we
see here today with our eyes.
The second thing I'm going to
do is just something I do when
I when I want to share
the code for shiny app,
but it's definitely
not always the case.
But I'm going to
add a GitHub banner.
I'll refer back to my repo.
I could do that really easily
with the GitLink package.
All I have to do
is use the function ribbon_CSS,
which comes in in
the Gitlink package.
This call it
inside my page, and
it takes the URL that that
I want to link back to. That's
gonna be URL of my GitHub repo,
put it there, and I'll run the app.
Now that I have the app
looking the way I want,
publishing the app for me
is really easy because I'm inside
Posit Workbench and I have
a Posit Connect account.
Posit Connect can host shiny
apps. And they're linked,
so I just click publish.
It asks me if I want
to publish this app,
And I want to publish
it or anything, finish the app.
Click publish. It says
there's already one there.
There is I showed you at
the start of the webinar,
I'm gonna replace
it with this one,
and now it's deploying
the finished app.
Close the preview
window. We could see
things happening down here.
And it's uploading everything
that Posit Connect is gonna
need to serve and run this app.
Try to open up a pop up
window. So here we go,
we can see the app.
While it loads the app,
I'll point out I have controls
over here that as the app owner
I could use to decide who can
see the app, I could limit
to specific users.
I'd add them here.
They'd be people who have
accounts on my Posit Connect.
I don't really
want to limit it.
Anyone on my Internet with
Posit Connect can look at this
one. I could also choose what URL
I want the app to be at,
finished app just fine for me,
so I'll leave that
the way it is.
And then I can even choose
what sort of resources,
compute resources.
I think this app needs to
support it as multiple users visited.
When it's all done,
or when I'm all done
making my selections,
I could share this URL with
anyone I want to see the app.
And it will appear
full page like this.
So there we go.
There's our published
styled Finished shiny app,
Thank you so much for sticking
through this with me and
learning so much about how
to style your shiny apps.
The take home messages
are use the bslib package,
use its excellent website,
which you could find through
Google to learn all about the
package, could lay out
your apps, create cards,
create value cards.
You could use classes,
CSS classes to change the
appearance of your app. You'd
use CSS variables
from the Bootstrap package,
and you could also use
themes from the Boot Swatch package.
If you have any questions,
drop it in the comments,
and we'll try your best
to answer them. Thank you.
Thank you so much, Garrett,
for the awesome demo,
and for sharing the
code with all of us.
YouTube should automatically push you
over into the live Q
and A room right now, but
if for any reason it doesn't,
it will be in the
YouTube description below as well,
and I'll put it in the chat.
We'd love to have you join us for
the q and a. And as a reminder,
you can use the YouTube chat
or the slido link on the screen
right now for
anonymous questions.
Also,
if you're curious to try
Posit Workbench or Posit Connect,
which you you saw today,
I've also included a link on
the screen to let us know and
chat with our team too.
With that, let's go jump over to the
Q and A. See you in a second.